hello my name is
today i'm going to talk about this topic
non-adaptive black box reductions
for basic auxiliary imp cryptography on
np hardness
so let's begin with introduction
so this work is related to these two
fields worst case hardness in complexity
theory and cryptography and as you know
there's a huge gap between these two
fields at present
and one of the most challenging tasks is
to construct runway functions based on
the hardness of np
problem in other words to show this
implication
one basic approach for this problem is
following
so let's say f is a candidate for
one-way function and
to construct a reduction from solving
some language
error to breaking or embedding this
function
f and if this problem l is np-half
problem
then we can show the above result
because this f is not one wave function
then we have some polynomial time
adversary for breaking f
and by using this reduction we can also
solve this problem l
in polynomial time so that's why we can
choose the counter position
but there's a specific barrier uh such a
reduction especially the type of
reduction that is non-adaptive black box
reductions
so in fact many brilliant results
in surgical computer science have been
developed by using such a very simple
form of reduction and in this case
non-adaptive black box reductions look
like
this figure so first this
reduction r is given some input x and
accesses to adversary for
f as black box and this r
uh makes its queries uh
parallel in one round and
if this adversary returns correct
answers
then this r can recognize the
characteristic of
x so this is very simple and
very familiar form of rejection but
unfortunately the previous works show
that if we can get such a reduction
for this problem then we can show errors
contained in
am intersect called m and if there is np
half problem
then this implies the collapse of
polynomial hierarchy so in other words
under very
reasonable assumption on polynomial
hierarchy we can exclude
such an attempt and this previous result
might
look a little negative but this gives
very important direction for us
the first one is developing non-black
box known black box
techniques and the second one is
developing
adaptive techniques but at present
there is a few success story on such a
somewhat complicated technique so it
might be very challenging task to
get such a primit such a reduction for
this problem
so the goal of this work is to
suggest the sub choice that is
to change the goal or in other words uh
to get a intermediate uh cryptographic
primitive instead of standard
cryptographic primitives
so in this work we focus on auxiliary
cryptographic primitives
as intermediate primitive and which is
originally introduced by ostrowsky and
rick johnson
and such a print bead is not
one specific function but uh defined as
a family of functions
and it has a weaker security condition
like this
so for each polynomial time adversary
depending on this adversary
there exists at least one secure
function for this adversary a in this
family
and the reason why such a primitive is
interesting
is breaking such a auxiliary input
cryptography
can be formulated as a kind of worst
case of average case
problem because uh for this fundamental
adversary this adversary must
break all functions in this family that
is worst case sense
but for each function the game for
breaking this primitive can be done
in average case sense because the
instance
is generated according to some
probabilistic procedure
that's why this is very a natural
intermediate model between usual worst
case hardness
and average case cryptography and in
fact there is a previous work
to exclude non-adaptive black box
reduction
from np-hard language to average case
problem
but uh it is not clear that we can uh
apply such a previous work to this
auxiliary
cryptography case and for more detailed
uh
observation for the reason why such a
previous one cannot be applied in this
case please refer to the proceedings
paper
but so that's why the
important question is so if we try to
get uh auxiliary cryptographic primitive
instead of uh
usual primitives uh whether non-adaptive
black box reduction
uh sufficient or not and we address this
question in this
work uh as a first step for
such a study on intermediate
cryptographic primitives
okay now let's see our results
but before rooking a result uh i will
explain more about non-adaptive black
box reduction
so r is a non-adaptive black box
reduction from a
language air to breaking some auxiliary
input premises b
if this r is polynomial time and
randomized and non-adaptive oracle
machine
and for any adversary a breaking this
primitive
and for any instance x of this problem l
this r given access to a can recognize
the
characteristic of this x with high
probability so this is a formal
definition
and in this work we consider very
fundamental three types of auxiliary
input primitive the first one
is the auxiliary input version of
pseudo-random generator
and the second one is one-way function
and the third one is
heating set generator so we consider
these
three imperatives and i will explain
later
the details for these primitives
so first i will show all the
relationships between these uh
among these primitives
for auxiliary in pseudonym generator and
auxiliary improvement function
so their existence are indeed equivalent
and the third one auxiliary heating set
generator is implied by the first one
second one
and in fact this is a much weaker
cryptographic prim tip
because it is weaker than the hardness
of running
so now let's see a result and so all
that is the following
if we can get an adaptive black box
reduction from this np heart problem
to breaking original pseudo-random
generator
then we can also show that the collapse
of polynomial hierarchy that's why under
the very
reasonable assumption we can exclude
such an attempt
and we also consider the case of
auxiliary function auxiliary
heating set generator like this and so
in this case in fact we could not show
a strong results such as collapse of
polynomial hierarchy but
we can show still very surprising
consequences
so that is we can extend this
relationship
to one way function which has infinitely
often security
is a inventory of security uh we adapted
black box reaction that's why we can get
np
based one-way function and in fact this
is
not strong to exclude such a
non-adaptive black box reduction
and it has two opposite interpretations
so negatively speaking this can be
regarded as a hardness result for
getting such another black box reaction
because
to get such an oddity black box
reduction
it's harder than to get np-based one-way
function
so this must be hardness negative result
but possibly speaking it can be also
regarded as a
a new approach for omp based only
function because
uh to construct a user one function we
don't need to
see a ram function anymore and all you
have to do is just uh
construct auxiliary uh cryptography be a
very simple
reduction uh but uh
for both perspective our work enhances
the
importance for of further research
on such intermediate cryptographic
springtip
and for the first result and second
result
some people might think why these
consequences are different because
this existence are equivalent so the
reason
is all of the known construction of
auxiliary
pseudonym generator based on huawei
function
uses some adaptive security reduction so
we cannot
uh translate this the second
uh no adaptive black box reduction into
the first non-adaptive block box
reduction without
losing any no adaptiveness
okay now let's move on to proof sketches
so
for each cryptographic primitive first i
will explain more about
each primitive and then we will show a
proof idea okay let's begin with uh the
case of auxiliary
pseudorandom generator and pseudorandom
genetics is roughly speaking
uh primitive uh for stretching a short
random seed
into a wrong pseudorandom string
and the auxiliary input analog is
defined as forward
so g is auxiliary inputs to the random
generator if this
is polynomial time computable and a
storage
function and there's no polynomial time
adversary which distinguishes this deep
and this
part means that for any auxiliary input
this a can distinguish through random
strings
and truly random strings with a
non-negligible
advantage
and now for the first result uh first
assume that
we assume that there is a non-adaptive
black box reduction from np
language to uh breaking auxiliary
pseudorandom generator and the goal is
to show the corrupts or polynomial
hierarchy and the key part of this proof
is to show this part no adaptive block
box reduction from this problem
to average case np problem in error
setting
and if you can get such a reduction then
we can also get an adaptive black box
reduction from np hand language
to average case problem so by using the
previous work
we can get the collapse of polynomial
arc and in fact
so this keypad is also very simple just
uh
we define this l prime as uh
the image of d like this and now assume
that uh
we have some errors heuristic scheme for
this problem f
prime let's say a and this errors part
means that the following this a
output zero one or some special symbol
bot
and if a output zero or one then this
must be correct answer
okay but uh a can also output
the sample bot but only on a small
fraction of
instances if we have such an errors
heuristic scheme then under enough
stretching of
g we can regard this a
as a valid uh adversary for this
perimeter
g because if this a is given
through random string then this string
must be contained in image of g that is
l prime
so a a must output one or both
because this a is errors on the other
hand
for almost all three random strings so
a output zero because the number of
pseudo-random strings
is a quite a few compared to
total random strings and
in fact this a can also output a bot
but only on small fraction that's why a
or for almost all to random strings this
a output zero
and this a can also distinguish
distinguish these two cases
that's why this a is a valid uh
distinguisher for
this uh generator g and
obviously this reduction is non-adaptive
black box reduction because
we use this uh this heuristic scheme
a only once that's why we can show
this result
okay now let's move on to the second
auxiliary input one way function
one function is lovely speaking a
function whose computation is very easy
but the task of inverting is very hard
and the auxiliary input analog
is defined as follows so f is
auxiliary input function if this is
polynomial time computable
and there exists a polynomial at point
number p
such that no polynomial time adversary a
can invert this
f with advantage in this value
and this part means that for any uh
auxiliary input
this a given functional value can
find one of inverse element
of the given input with this advantage
and this is a formal definition and for
the second result
first we assume that there exists a no
adaptive black box reduction r
from np hard language to breaking
auxiliary improvement function
and the goal is to extend this result to
one wave function so this is a key part
in this work
so provided the following first and now
we have a
a candidate for auxiliary functions so
we can translate it
into auxiliary imp pseudo-random
generator by using standard
cryptographic technique
via adaptive security reaction then we
can use the first result
so we can map this uh into the problem
np
sorry uh average case np problem then
the goal is to show this part
and since this l prime is in b problem
and this l is np heart problem so we
also have a cup reduction from l prime
to m
then we consider the following procedure
for
this average case problem first we
select
n primes instance x prime at random
then we put it into a cup reduction
then we translate it into earth instance
and now this x is else instance so we
can put
so we can use this reduction we can put
it into
r with uh randomness and
uh since this r is uh no adaptive black
box reduction so this
r uh can output
several queries apparently and if we can
answer these queries by some inverting
oracle or for
f then this r must output l of x
and this must be equal to l prime of x
prime
because of the condition of the cap
reduction
that's why this process can correctly as
a characteristic
of this x prime and the key
observation here is in this procedure
there is no worst case sense at all
because this input is selected at random
and this
is also circuit at random so perfectly
average case
and that's why these queries or
more specifically these auxiliary inputs
are also selected
according to some poisson problem or
distribution
and originally this inverting oracle can
invert
any primitives for any auxiliary input
but in this procedure this inverting
oracle
does not need a break or auxiliary
input anymore and this
eye a only need to uh
invert functions uh with respect to such
a
polynomial sample distribution and this
idea leads to
a construction of one function so let's
say the candidate is f
and this f takes 4 input
and this f imitates above procedure
as far as so first put this x prime
into the cup reduction and the resulting
is a put resulting instance into uh
blackbox reduction are with the given
randomness then these are output several
queries then
this function choose one of the
auxiliary
input and this i is a random input here
and output the functional value like
this so f g i
of x f and x f is also a random input
for
f and so intuitively speaking this f
imitates uh above procedure especially
the situation
of this part so if we have a adversary
for this
function f then with hyperbolic with
high probability we can x
we can replace the inverting oracle with
this
adversary and in fact this is a little
technical part but if
we can also make this procedure errors
so roughly speaking this is because uh
this r is uh yeah this reduction
in assumptions and if we can give a
uh inverting oracles and this r has a
potential for solving any instance x
that's why by using a proper testing
method for
this adversary we can make this
process errors and we can show this part
uh because yeah we can reduce uh
average case problem in error setting to
inverting some uh polynomial sorry
one function that's why we can show the
second result
okay now let's move on to the final
third result uh
auxiliary in protecting set generator
so heating set to generator is roughly
speaking one-sided error version of a
pseudo-random generator and defined as
follows so
d is auxiliary inputting set generator
if
it is polynomial time computable
stretching function and
there is no polynomial time adversary
which about
this generator g and which this part
means that for any auxiliary input
this a accepts large fraction of
randomness random strings
but this a does not accept
any pseudo-random string
generated by this gz or
like this figure so a accepts large
fraction of randomness but
avoids the image of g d
and this is a formal definition and for
the
for the third result first we assume
that uh no adaptive black box reduction
are from np-hard language to breaking uh
auxiliary heating set generator and goal
is to extend this
to one way function and the proof
is originally motivated the previous
work for
hitting the generator
so let's say these queries are generated
uh
by this r and the key idea
is to divide these queries into light
queries and
heavy queries as far as so without loss
of generality first we can assume that
these queries sorry for these queries
the modular distributions are equivalent
to some specific
distribution q x this is done by
applying permutations over the positions
of queries
before asking them and we also use the
notation on p
of y by d
to refer to the conditional probability
that
this queries generated a con condition
on
the usually input is d and we also set a
a proper threshfold tau like this then
we define
light queries as queries whose
conditional probability is
less than or equal to
this search for and otherwise we define
such queries as heavy queries
and in the end we will answer these
right
queries by 1 and heavy queries by 0.
so for simplicity let
o l denote
such a oracle and if this o l is a valid
avoiding oracle for this generator then
uh
this reduction r giving access to o l
can uh correctly ask the characteristic
of this
input x so now let's see
several observations for this oracle
in fact so this ol can accept large part
of
random strings and in fact we can
easily show that the number of heavy
queries
is bounded by the inverse of tau
threshold and which is much smaller than
the total number of
pseudo random strings
but there is there are two problems
about
this oracle the first one in fact this
is not a
valid avoiding oracle for this g
because there exists this type of
queries
we call such a queries as
bad queries and the reason why this uh
but uh it's
uh so this bad query is
right query so that's why this ol is
the answer of this ol is one but
by the second condition the correct
answer must be zero so this o l cannot
uh as a correctly such a bad queries
that's why this o is not valid
uh avoiding oracle and the second
problem is
we do not know how to simulate such an
oracle
because yeah more specifically we do not
how to determine the given queries
light or heavy
but in fact the first one is not so
problematic
in this case because the probability is
such a bad query is generated according
to this distribution is very small
this is roughly because
for each auxiliary input d the
conditional probability
[Music]
that this right query is generated it's
very small
by the definition of write query and
in fact the total number but query is is
also all small
because the number of this
image is g is also small
and in fact we can show we can bounce
such about a probability above by
a one over polynomial
of the length of d
and that's why so this o l is invalid uh
uh avoiding oracle but with high
probability
over the execution of reduction r
this o oll behaves like a valid oracle
so we can
conquer this problem and for the second
problem
the key part is estimating the keypad is
the task of estimating
this value to determine light or heavy
and for this problem we apply
a universal extrapolation technique
developed by a
in progression living for auxiliary
input setting and we reduce this task of
estimating
to uh the task of inverting some
auxiliary input function
and by more uh careful observation in
fact this
we can show that this reduction is
indeed no adaptive black box
so we use these two observations
and we can by these techniques
we can reduce this task to
breaking auxiliary input one-way
function
via non-adaptive black box reduction
that's why we have
now we have another black box reaction
from
np head language to inverting auxiliary
input one way function
then we can use the second result now so
we
translate this problem into breaking
pseudorandom generator and we also
translate this problem to average case
problem then we can
construct np-based one-way function
that's why we can show the third result
okay in conclusion in this work we
consider no adapt
block box reduction from np-hard
language to
intermediate auxiliary input primitives
especially we consider these three
primitives pseudonym generator of a
function heating set generator
in the case of auxiliary in
pseudo-random generator we can exclude
such a non-adaptive black box reduction
under the reserve assumption on
polynomial hierarchy
and in the cases of auxiliary
development function and obviously in
treating the generator
we show that such a non-adaptive black
box reduction
implies a np-based one-way function and
this can be
regarded as a positively speaking a new
approach for np-based one-way function
and the important future direction is to
verify the validity of this positive
perspective and i will share with you
more two directions the first one is to
consider other cases where
such intermediate primitives or
intermediate problems
might be helpful for constructing such a
np-based one-way function
and i believe that this direction will
help
to reduce the task of constructing
np-based warming function to much
smaller
intermediate path and to identify the
hard core
uh to show such an np-based wave
function
but uh yeah there is still possibility
that
these non-adaptive black box reduction
also
implies implied the collapse of
polynomial hierarchy
that's why the second direction is to
exclude such an adaptive black box
reduction especially for
one auxiliary input one-way function and
i guess the most natural approach to
show this part is to construct auxiliary
imp
pseudo random generator based on
exchange function
the non-adaptive black box security
reaction but at present at least i
uh do not have any idea to construct
such a
very simple security reaction
okay that's all thank you for your
attention